in part you are a bit of a snake
Whisperer so what what is it that
that others don't understand that you do
about snakes
what's maybe a misconception
or what what is uh what have you learned
from the language you speak that snakes
understand I don't know it's just it's
an animal that has has many times in my
life I've been responsible for helping
um the you know I started catching
snakes when I was very young I'd watch
Steven wouldn't go out and catch a
garter snake or a black rat snake in New
York and
um and then I had a rule I said I have
to catch a hundred non-venomous snakes
before I'm allowed to handle a venomous
snake if I ever need to handle a
venomous snake and then you know I was
on a trail one time I think in Harriman
State Park and some guy you know like
some big hero he tells us you know he's
like back up I'm gonna get this and he
like picks up a stick and he like goes
to like assault this poor Copperhead
that's sitting on the trail
and so like at like 16 years old I had
to go and like shoulder this guy out of
the way and I like got the thing by the
tail and used a stick to very gently
just put it off the trail
Copperhead was not going to do anything
to him but he wanted to you know beat
his chest and show his wife that he was
tough
um but then in India you know I've lived
in India for five years at this point in
and out you know periodically and and
snakes are always getting into people's
kitchens
um one time we had a king cobra get into
someone's kitchen an 11 foot snake like
a monster like a god of a snake this
thing stood up you know it would stand
up and be able to look at you over the
table
and this terrifying monster thing
um giant gorilla dog thing like
we caught it with one of the local snake
catchers and we brought it out and he
goes
you know I wonder why I was in the
kitchen yeah looking for food and they
go no they eat snakes king cobra opio
figures Hannah they eat snakes
and he goes
she's thirsty
and so we got a bottle of water and we
got footage of this and we she's
standing up she's going don't make me
kill you don't make me kill you you're
scaring me right now I don't want to
kill you we took the bottle of the water
and we poured it on our nose and she
started she started drinking you can see
you could see her just drinking and the
snake just took this long drinks drank a
whole water bottle and then said thank
you so much and crawled off and it's
like to me the fact that people are
scared of snakes they have symbolic
hatred of snakes you know you you know
someone's evil and sneaky we call them a
snake and like to me it's like when I
take volunteers or researchers or
students out into the jungle and we find
an emerald tree boa or an Amazon Tree
Boa or or a vine snake and it's like
this is it's one of the few animals like
you can't really catch a bird and show
it to people you're gonna scare the
birds feathers are going to come out you
might give it a heart attack snakes you
can lift up a snake you know if there's
a snake in the room right now I could
lift it up and say Lex here this is how
you hold it and we could interact calmly
with this thing and then put it back on
its branch and then it'll go and I've
seen what that does to people I've seen
how the Wonder in their eyes and so to
me snakes have always been this
incredible link to teach people about
Wildlife about nature because they have
naturally a lot of fear towards this
creature and to realize that the fear is
not justified it's not grounded or is
not as deeply grounded in reality of
course there's always New Yorker snakes
right there's always going to be an
snake here and there coming for
me man
uh well okay so back to the Anaconda how
do you catch an anaconda like what uh
how do you hand because it's such a 25
foot or even 12 foot yeah these giant
snakes how do you how do you deal with
this creature how do you interact with
them we had to learn how to do that
because one of the first ones we caught
that I would say maybe like a 16 footer
which is no joke of a snake you know
girth of a basketball let's say
um you know we're on the canoe and this
is this is the early days like you know
now we're at a whole different level but
this is back when we were Barefoot and
shirtless and just guys in the Amazon
and JJ's like you know you know I just
listened to him he'd be like get off the
boat you come from the top we're gonna
come from the bottom so okay I just did
as I was told
I came in the snake is all curled up
dead asleep she's got some butterflies
on her eyes trying to get salt and stuff
and all of a sudden I see the tongue so
I'm like she's awake and I'm like guys
and like they're they're paying
attention to not crashing the boat to
getting over there and we're all trying
to run snake starts going into the water
so I run ahead grab this snake get her
by the head so you got her by the head
you think okay you can't she can't get
me I got it right behind the head and
it's about this thick the neck what's
that feel like excited to interrupt like
grabbing this thing with this giant head
it's exciting it's amazing it's it's
scary how hard is it to hold it's not
that hard to hold the scary part is the
moment of it's like if you ever done
like a cliff dive or something it's that
moment where you go do it do it the time
like do it and your body's going do not
do that yeah and then you're like I
gotta just do it and you do it yeah
because you can't just gently like flirt
with it you have to cry no and it's like
it's like crossing the street when
there's a bus coming it's like you
hesitate it's more dangerous you know so
like you just you go for it and I got
her and I was like I got her
and then a coil goes over my wrists and
all of a sudden my wrists slap together
and you feel this squeeze that can crush
the bones out of an animal bigger than
me and the next coil comes very quickly
over my neck and now I'm on my knees
with my arms tied if I wanted to let go
of the snake I couldn't and my shoulders
are coming together my collarbone is
about to break and I tried to yell for
JJ and all that came out was there's
nothing and so that's what they do to
their prey you know so I attacked as far
as the snake knows I attacked she
doesn't know that I just want to measure
her you you started as the big spoon but
then the snake became the big it very
much became the big spoon and uh I was I
would say I was 15 seconds away from
having my entire rib cage collapsed and
then JJ showed up and grabbed the tail
and just started unwrapping this thing
and then we got but now we have a system
now we know like you know I'm always
I've done I've gotten more head catches
than anybody so I'm usually Point guy
and you know you get you're the you're
the the first the the point guy okay the
the taking the big risky yes First Step
yes although it could be argued that
there's a similarly large risk for the
tail guy because the anaconda's defense
is to take a giant projectile and
so the person that gets the tail is
gonna smell like Anaconda for like at
least a week yes it's the least Pleasant
you're taking the the most dangerous one
there
um they have the least Pleasant job this
is fascinating but what's really
fascinating though is that because of
the apex predator they're they're eating
the fish they're eating the birds
they're eating everything and everything
in this riparian ecosystem is absorbing
the Mercury that's coming off the gold
mining in the region and so anacondas
can be
indicative for us of how is Mercury
moving through this ecosystem and this
is a region where we've lost hundreds of
thousands of acres to artisanal gold
mining where they use mercury to bind
the gold they cut the forest burn the
forest
and then they run water through the sand
and the sand particles have bits of gold
in it not chunks but just little almost
microscopic flecks of gold and then they
use the Mercury to bind that and then
they burn off the Mercury and that Vapor
goes up into the clouds just like
everything else it's all connected down
there and then rains down into the
rivers and so the people in the region
are having birth defects from the amount
of Mercury
that's in the water and so we were
starting at at one point when we were
doing most of our Anaconda research we
were learning things like these animals
actually aren't just Ambush Predators
which is what most of the literature
will tell you is that anacondas are
Ambush predators no they actually go
hunting they'll go find clay licks and
salt deposits and they'll wait there
they'll actually pursue animals and we
were trying to take tissue samples to
find out if anacondas could be used to
study how Mercury is moving through the
ecosystem and so that was really it
became can we use these animals not only
as ambassadors for wildlife because
everybody wants to see the anacondas but
also
you know what can we learn from studying
this very very little understood apex
predator and one of the things you can
learn is how Mercury moves through
through the ecosystem which can damage
the ecosystem with all kinds of
different ways yeah it's it's brutal man
the the gold mining that's happening
down there is is it's funny because
we've been hearing a lot recently about
like the Cobalt mines in Africa and it's
like where we are in the Amazon
um we were down there with ABC News I
want to say like a year and a half ago
um with my friend Matt Gutman who's the
chief correspondent for ABC and we he
wanted to see the Amazon fires he wanted
to see some Wildlife he wanted to see
the areas that we're protecting and then
he goes I want to see
the gold mining areas and and I'd never
gotten in so deep but we we met these
Russian guy you can't go with the
proving they will kill you like our
lawyer's father was was assassinated for
standing up to the gold miners
there was two Russian guys though who
had a legal mining concession somehow
way out past the machine gun guarded
limit of the pumpus which is where they
do all this gold mining and we got in
there and
took footage of the desert that is
forming in what used to be the
headwaters of the Amazon rainforest and
it's like there's a massive global scale
ecological crime happening down there
that you can see from space
from this unregulated gold mining and
the cops can't go there because they
will be murdered it's completely Lawless
what's the machine gun limit exactly
it's the border of this area that they
call the pompous which is where the
rainforest has been cut and completely
destroyed and it looks like Mars it's
just sand
and inside of this area are gold miners
and we you know we tried to get in there
to film years ago and there's just a lot
of guys with machine guns who don't let
that happen and what the Russian guys
you guys had access somehow they'd come
down with a bit of money and they had a
new system yeah and actually what was
interesting is while I was in there
they're very friendly and a really
really too friendly uh gold miners and
they uh one of them while I was there he
uh you know he kind of tapped me on the
shoulder he was like you know look at
those guys he was like those guys over
there he goes I just heard them say your
name
and he goes That's not a good thing he
goes they know exactly who you are he
goes I wouldn't keep posting to
Instagram about gold mining in the
Amazon and I was like okay thanks for
the warning and then you know uh in June
somebody pulled up beside me on a
motorcycle and I got a more Stern
warning but they pay attention to the
flow of information because they don't
want the world to yeah to find out oh
the last thing they want is to be shut
down but the gold miners are notorious
for
you know just uh whacking people and
throwing them in a in a pile of you know
gold mining leftovers it's really like
like the Peruvian government has to get
the military to go after them like the
work we've done with gold miners
converting them into conservationists
has all been like I mean I've seen the
Peruvian Navy come down and literally
blow up gold mining barges and you know
it's it's a war it's a war being fought
in the Amazon
so it's a it's possible to convert them
into conservationists what's that
process like or is that like uh you say
that in jest no I say that in an
absolute sincerity we we went up River
uh up the malinowski river several years
ago and I think it was 2018 and everyone
everyone was like you are going to die
like you will be shot and killed and uh
the reason we were able to do it with
relative safety was that the Gold Miner
that we were going with
was the brother-in-law of one of my
closest friends down there our
Expedition chef and one of the directors
of jungle Keepers and I said look you
can go just keep a low profile and so I
went up with a photographer and we spent
a week there and
dead animals everywhere deforestation
everywhere I mean the things we saw were
so horrible and we're living with these
gold miners that are you know they're
they're getting their gold they're
burning off the Mercury I watched the
guy smoking a cigarette burning the
Mercury off of his gold with the with
the vapor going straight into his face
with his child right there I mean
unbelievable negligence of just sanity
just and then and then towards the end
of the week the Peruvian Navy comes down
the river and everyone starts scrambling
and I was like I'm just gonna sit here
with my hands up because you know
and they didn't even stop they they
found the gold mining barge you know
they have a floating thing in the river
that just plums the bottom of the river
just sucks all the all the sediment up
and they stopped and they strapped a
bunch of explosives to this motor and
good Lord the the sound of this
explosion and there's just hot metal
raining down all over the place and then
they just went a bunch of guys in
fatigues and they just kind of like
looked at us like peace and I sat there
with this Gold Miner and I went now what
and he went well now I gotta go get a
new motor and I went why don't you just
do something else and he goes what else
is there and I went look what we do and
I sat there with my phone and I was like
see this these are pretty tourists and
we feed them food and we show them
tarantulas and macaws and they and he
looked at this and he went wow
he goes you
he goes that looks like so much fun and
when it is so much fun so we show people
we bring students to the Jungle
he goes so you're saying if I build you
a lodge you'll bring people I said yeah
and I came back a year later and he sat
there with a with a chainsaw a hand saw
and some nails and he cut down like 17
palm trees and he built an ecotourism
Lodge
so you give them another channel of
survival of making money and that's what
we've been doing through jungle Keepers
for loggers and for all kinds of
extractors it's just saying look what do
you make you make 15 a day destroying
the ancient trees of the Jungle what if
we paid you 35 a day to have a uniform
and a job and health insurance and
security and you just protect it and use
all of the Jungle knowledge you've
gained as a logger to protect this place